- What's up Believe Nation?
Happy weekend, it's Evan.
I'm thinkin of launching
a new potential t-shirt
and I need your feedback.
(joyful beat music)
So there's this great clip
of Sylvester Stallone talking
about how to him no means yes.
It's one of my favorite clips of him.
- In this whole world, turns you on?
- Challenge, it really does.
I just love, I love it.
You know, I love being told "No."
- Gotcha.
- It just means yes.
(laughter)
No?
- To you?
- Yeah
- What turns you off?
- Lack of enthusiasm really turns me off.
- So I love the message of
perseverance and I thought,
I want to turn that into a t-shirt.
For myself to wear, for you guys to wear.
And I hired a designer
to come up with a bunch
of different designs.
It think we have 10 different designs.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
I'm going to to link them
up in the description.
We're going to to show a quick
preview of them on the screen.
Right now they're appearing.
Let me know which one
you guys like the best.
Check out the description.
And if there's other
quotes or entrepreneurs
that you would love to see turned
into a t-shirt, let me know.
I think it's important, you know.
What you wear is an
expression of yourself.
You know I have my Believe clothing on.
And I'm lookin to expand.
And so your feedback
is highly appreciated.
Thank you guys for the love.
Hope you have an amazing weekend.
Continue to believe and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(energetic music)